on parle de ces noms qui ont été donnés
des accusés du meurtre de Thomas
fallait-il donner les noms donc voilà on
va voir je vais voir ce qu'on pense les
téléspectateur s'il vous plaît merci si
on peut avoir oui à 90 % voilà 90 % des
Français pensent qu'il fallait donner
les noms euh voilà donc c'est quand même
un un score très très important et donc
pour la plupart des Français il fallait
donner les noms Gilles voilà vous voyez
on va on va parler maintenant de Patrick
Cohen qui a été lyché sur les réseaux
pour n'avoir donné que la version des
accusés du meurtre de Thomas à il
déraperé c'est la question que je vous
pose pour beaucoup c'est oui euh Patrick
Cohen donc si vous ne le connaissez pas
c'est un éditorialiste hein qui était
qui éta en émission sur France 5 il
faisait un édito sur le meurtre du jeune
Thomas sauf que sa façon de relaté les
fait a choqué les internautes ne donnant
que la version des assassins avez-vous
été choqué a-t-il dérapé on va voir un
premier extrait comment son éditau par
la raison de pourquoi la soirée a
dégénéré euh donc il trouve des des des
des excuses à à ce ce ce meurtre cet
assassinat Patrick Cohen voilà une fois
de plus le donneur de leçon a frappé
regardez dans ce village de la Drome de
500 habitants il y avait un bal dans la
salle des fêtes en fin de soirée une
dizaine de jeunes se mêlent aux 400
participants ils ne sont pas du village
ils sont venus pour s'amuser pour
draguer des filles pas d'incident
jusqu'à la dernière chanson de la soirée
Chikita du rappeur Jules c'est là que
d'après les mises en cause l'un des
participants au bal un rugby man aurait
tiré les cheveux longs d'un des membres
du groupe en le traitant de Chikita
c'està-dire de filles sexy altercation
bagarre les offensés sortent des
couteaux un adolescent de 16 ans
s'effondre poignardé à mort il
s'appelait Thomas il jouit au rugby
c'était l'une de ses premières sorties
ensuite il explique que rien ne prouve
que ce groupe de jeunes nétait venu
casser du blanc regardez leur prénom les
désignne c'est long que les musulmans
sont dangereux par nature que le racisme
antiblanc frappe jusque dans nos
campagnes a dit Marion maréchal avec des
milices armées qui opèrent des RADIAS
Marine Le Pen et qui commettent des
francocides Éric Zemour la mort de
Thomas ne résulte pas d'un règlement de
compte ou d'une expédition punulitive
même si les insultes racistes ont bien
été entendu par neuf témoins lors de la
bagarre contre les Blancs du village
cette motivation raciste n'a pas été
retenu par la justice rien ne prouve que
les jeunes du quartier de la monnaie
étaient venus casser du blanc
et puis ensuite il évoque les les prises
de position de la droite et de l'extrême
droite voulons nous faire croire qu'en
France il y a une chasse au Gaulois
regardez la presque centaine de
militants d'ultra drroite descendu en
représaille à roman sur iser n'étaient
pas des manifestants ils étaient
cagoulés et armés de barredefire ils ne
sont pas venus faire justice même ils
étaient venus pour châtier des Arabes ce
qu'on continue d'appeler hélas une
ratonade la droite et l'extrême droite
veulent nous faire croire que nous
sommes au bord de la guerre civile
qu'une France se dresse contre une autre
que la chasse au gaulois est lancé alors
que l'immense majorité des immigrés et
des Français issus de l'immigration
réprouvent cette violence Stanislas
Rigon c'est honteux c'est honteux pour
plusieurs raisons et pour la première
c'est que Patrick Cohen il est sur le
service public le service public et
l'audiovisuel public ça coûte 4
milliards par an ça a même été augmenté
en septembre 2023 de 6 % donc ça c'est
la première chose le service public
c'est la maison de tous les Français et
ce qu'il vient de faire là aujourd'hui
c'est cracher au visage sûrement de
millions et de millions de Français
parce que quand on entend Patrick en
minim les fait trouver des excuses en
tout cas trouver des des des
circonstances atteignantes à des types
qui sont venus avec des lames de 20 cm à
une soirée mais c'est hallucinant
c'estàdire que moi si je viens à une
soirée selon ces terme pour les
reprendre pour draguer ou m'amuser mais
pardon moi quand je drague et je m'amuse
à la à la limite je ramène un pack
deuken mais je ramène pas une lame et
mes copains pour me battre et puis sur
les témoins évidemment ce qui est
choquant c'est que il prend la version
des accusés des suspects de l'affaire
des assassins de de Thomas mais il
minimise les neuf personnes qui ont dit
qu'ils avaient entendu des insultes et
du racisme antiblanc il ne parle pas des
cinq personnes qui évoquent les menaces
de mort et il ne parle pas des 12
personnes entendues sur les sur la plus
de centaine de personnes qui ont été
entendu qui disent qu'ils ont entendu
des sa plante ça plante ça plante s
plante alors franchement si toutes les
personnes qui viennent à des soirées
pour draguer qui si toutes les personnes
qui écoute du Jul et entend Chikita se
mettre à poignarder des gens mais les
Thomas ça sera pas tous les jours ce
sera toutes les secondes malad C G c'est
une séquence qui a été signalée à
l'arcom apparemment on voit les
signalements àcom on a vu ce qui s'est
passé pour Guillaume Meuris il a eu une
mise en garde voilà rien du tout il a
une mise en garde Guillaume Guillaume
mer c'est une mise en garde on aurait
fait la même séquence sur TPMP c'était 4
millions non mais après on va nous dire
qu'il y a pas de poids de mesure c'est
quand même incroyable et vous allez voir
que je vous le dis tout de suite Patrick
Cohen n'aura rien du tout mise en garde
pareil mais c'est sûr et certain il aura
rien je vous le signe aujourd'hui pas
besoin d'attendre c'est vrai couna mais
néanmoins avec reconquête Mar Marchal
nous avons également sais parce qu'on
peut pas laisser peut-être mais en tout
cas je crois qu'il faut alerter les
Français essayer de faire comprend
queand c'est pour tes PMP là il y a de
l'argent ah comme il a donné une marque
tout à l'heure on va se rappeler que
l'AB d'alcool est dangereux pour la
santé pouront pasous saisir à côté de
la qu'est-ce qui lui est arrivé à
Patrick Cohen je sais pas je comprends
pas du tout parce que en fait il nous
donne une grande leçon comme s'il allait
nous expliquer cette affaire alors
l'enquête est extrêmement complexe pour
le moment monsieur Rigo le le la théorie
raciste n'est pas retenue on le sait bon
voilà c'est c'est les responsabilités
sont difficiles à établir mais la
manière dont lui il va du côté des mis
en cause c'est scandaleux voilà c'est
impossible on peut pas faire ça on peut
pas faire ça on n pas le droit tout
simplement je pense que Daniel va être
non mais il a il a fait mieux que
minimiser c'est-à-dire qu'en fait il a
fait il a dit clairement que un des
rugbyman celui qui aurait touché les
cheveux a provoqué a provoqué le le
futur assassin il sera responsable vous
imaginez ce jeune rugby Man qui va se
dire si ça se trouve je suis responsable
de la de la mort de de Thomas de mon
copain non mais on marche sur la tête
parce qu'en plus quand on il dit à un
moment je crois qu'on l'a pas entendu là
mais les fait rien que les fait moi j'ai
lu tout le déroulé du procureur il en
raconte le le premier quart parce que
ensuite d'accord il y a peut-être eu
cette bagarre c'est une ligne dans le
truc du procureur c'est peut-être vrai
mais il avait l'assassin enfin le
présumé assassin avait donné un couteau
à l'entrée mais quand il sort il en
ressort un autre parce qu'il en avait un
deuxè dans son sac ça
patrien aime les fait mais là il ne nous
le dit pas ça et ensuite il y a deux
voitures qui arrivent avec des gens
armés c'est pour ça que les gens croient
à un attentat et tout ça ça il ne nous
le dit pas non plus alors des faits des
faits mais pas tous les faits merci
voilà il quand je l'ai entendu Patrick
il était à deux doigts pratiquement dire
que c'est eux qui sont défendus en fait
ils sont défendus parce qu'ils étaient
chatouillés ou énervés par par les
rubbyan et cetera mais et Patrick qui
dit ils sont venus s'amuser d' tbadin
ils sont venus s'amuser draguer les
filles qui va s'amuser avec une lame à
cout une lame de 25 cm c'est ça la
longueur ça qui va s'amuser avec une
lame de 25 cm faut être complètement je
plains la famille qui a D qui a dû
mourir une deuxième fois d'entendre des
des des horreurs comme ça qu il sont V
suser Mo je le envoie vraimentp beaucoup
de force à tout le village qui m'ont
écrit un mot exceptionnel je voulais le
dire les gens du village qui m'ont écrit
un mot ce weekend exceptionnel et je le
je tenais je tenais à les remercier
parce qu' qui a un mot qui m'a
énormément touché après le le le passage
des deux témoins la semaine dernière et
ils m'ont écrit un mot sur weekend voilà
par SMS de long SMS et qui m'ont
vraiment beaucoup touché donc merci à
toutes les personnes du village et on
pense très fort à à la famille de de de
Thomas mundir toi tu tu penses qu' tu
penses qu'il a pas dérapé non non moi il
a dérapé non il a dérapé il a dérapé non
non moi il a dérapé bien évidemment il
faut de toute façon ça ramènera pas le
jeune Thomas P à son âme ça ça paisera
pas ses parents ce qui s'est passé juste
une abonination c'est c'est je sais pas
je sais pas quoi dire par rapport à ça
il va y avoir une justice il faut que la
justice soit soit terrible là-dessus et
qu'elle donne exemple tout simplement
oui je suis d'accord avec lui c'est la
justice en fait le problème c'est pas de
savoir les noms et les prénoms de qui
ont fait ça en fait on s'en fout des
noms moi je m'en fous de savoir si c'est
Saïd qui est parti dans une Rix ou si
c'est Bernard qui a violé une gamine ou
si c'est Jean-Pierre qui a agressé une
jogueuse je m'en fous moi qu'on div
divul les noms je veux qu'il a une
réponse judiciaire je veux qu'il a une
réponse pénale quand j'entends patrien
qui dit rien de prouve qu'ils sont venus
là pouragarer ou rien de prouve qu'ils
sont venus là casser du blanc si tu vas
dans une soirée avec des lames si tu vas
dans une soirée avec des couteaux et que
tu t'en sers alors que le mec avait même
pas le droit de porter des des armes
parce qu'il avait déjà été condamné si
tu vas parce que déjà tu as rien à
dans cette fête en fait quand je
reprends là je suis en train de repenser
c'est une fête de village ils sont entre
eux ils sont vous prenez votre voiture
vous venez d'un autre village pour
draguer des meufs ça part en couille
vous sortez des couteaux il y a rien qui
va dans cette affaire mais lui je veux
pas qu'il soit mort pour rien et j'ai
bien peur que bah il va être mort pour
rien et qu'on va reparler d'une autre
affaire dans 2 mois il y aura un autre
Thomas qui se sera fait poignarder et le
débat ce sera mais qui qui l'a poignardé
Bernard Patrick Saïd ou moi-même ou
Mohamed je m'en fous moi qui l'a
poignardé je veux que la réponse je veux
que le mec quand il vient avec une lame
il se disent non mais je m'en fous mais
sur Patrick CEN il est complètement à la
plaque il est complètement à côté de la
plaque il il minimise un truc où c'est
un assassinat on peut pas faire une
tribune pendant 2 minutes et minimiser
un assassinat en disant ils sont juste
venus danser sur du jou c'est parti en
cacahuète il l'a planté bon les mec ça
arrive partout non ça n'arrive pas
partout ce qui s'est passé il a dit ça
comme si c'était une une bagarre sur sur
le d'une gare ou une bagarre dans un
stade de foot ou une bagarre à l'école
c'est très grave ce qui s'est passé si
lui il croit que c'est pas grave bah
Patrick Cohen bah je sais pas s'il a des
enfants ou pas si on avait fait ça un de
ses enfants je peux te dire qu'il dit
pas la même c'est pas la même version
c'est pas le même éedito je peux te le
dire mais JAC Patrick Cohen est un
excellent journaliste mais je trouve que
il a commis une erreur journalistique
fondamentale c'est qu'il a pioché dans
le discours et dans les faits qui sont
donnés par le procureur de la République
des faits qu'il l'arrange pour pouvoir
écrire une autre histoire que l'histoire
finale on n'est pas au bout de l'enquête
et je vais te donner qure non mais après
tu vas donner les quatre trucs juste
petite question on n'est pas dans un
truc aussi et je le dis parce que je
vois je vois plein de choses en ce
moment il y a plein de journalistes
aussi qui prennent souvent le contrepied
juste pour faire le buzz et je vous dis
la vérité moi je crois qu'on est même
ces journalistes qui se disent des
journalist des journalistes du service
public je suis désolé les gars il nous
il nous reproche tout le temps de nous
faire du buzz nous nous on fait pas du
buzz on est comme ça nous en fait c'est
notre c'est je vous dire c'est moi c'est
je parle comme je suis dans la vie donc
forcément ça fait du buzz ici on est en
direct mais moi je le soupçonne je le
dis d'avoir voulu faire du buzz et de
dire je vais prendre le contrepied et
d'ailleurs c'est ce qu'il a fait et à un
moment je vais vous dire le problème
c'est qu'il a les journalistes
aujourd'hui il y en a il y en a beaucoup
qui pensent qu'à faire parler d'eux et
qui ne donnent pas les bonnes infos et
qui sont maintenant dans un dans une
recherche de buzz et c'est extrêmement
grave et c'est ce qui fait
qu'aujourd'hui avant on avait les
journalistes qu'on appelle les putacliqu
et pu il y avait les journalistes un peu
plus sérieux et c'est vrai que de plus
en plus même des journalistes un peu
plus sérieux essaient de faire du buzz
on le voit c'est très frappant c'est
très frappant et c'est les alors les
quatre points d'abord un la bagarre
n'exclut pas l'expédition c'estàdire que
lui il parle de ce nouveau fait selon
autour de cette chanson chitita ça ne
veut pas dire que il y a pas eu puisque
c'est ce que dit le procureur de
véhicules qui arrivent juste après et
que il y a eu à ce moment là aussi une
sortie de couteau il ne donne pas
l'espace-temp qu'il y a entre la
dernière chanson et euh ce qu'on appelle
une bagarre à la fin mais moi j'ai pas
envie de parler de bagarre pour moi ça
reste une expédition punitive donc ça
c'est le premier point le deuxième c'est
que depuis quand on donne une partie des
faits mais pas les autres
journalistiquement c'est extrêmement
grave surtout venant de sa part
puisqu'il veut essayer de mettre un
point final à ce qui a été dit et en
fait il choisit encore une fois un
certain nombre de faits il y a un autre
point qui me choque beaucoup c'est le
côté bagarre de rugbyan on est habitué à
ça dans les villages il y a quelque
chose voilà c'est les rugbyman qu'on
voulu faire le coup de point je termine
et ça c'est extrmement choquant moi je
connais plein de de balles avec des
rugby dans le Gers ou dans les Landes ça
se termine pas par des coups de couteau
de 25 cm et le dernier point qui est
presque le plus choquant c'est que je
pense qu'il a voulu faire cette
chronique pour distiller le doute que on
s'était tous trompés depuis le début et
que il s'agissait de battre en brèche
totalement l'idée selon laquelle
s'appuie un certain nombre de parti
politique il faut pas non plus être DUP
de ça mais l'idée selon laquelle c'est
une expédition punitive c'est pas ça le
problème le problème c'est qu'il y a la
mort d'un gamin et que il y a eu quelque
chose d'absolument terrible qui a choqué
la France entière parce que c'était une
bande de jeunes de de jeunes saisou qui
sont allés tuer un un pauvre homme un
pauvre garçon de 16 ans et ça c'est
c'est c'est absolument terrible mais en
fait je crois que c'est hyper
intéressant ce qui vient d'être dit
c'està-dire que oui Patrick Cohen a
voulu se payer les partis politiques qui
sont ses adversaires parce qu'en réalité
Patrick Cohen oui il a sa carte de
presse sûrement oui il a été journaliste
un temps mais aujourd'hui c'est un
idéologue aujourd'hui il est dans un
combat lui aussi politique et son combat
politique c'est de minimiser les fait
mais franchement et ça a été dit mais ce
drame mais qui est si courant
aujourd'hui dans notre pays parce qu'
encore à Rennes ce weekend il y a eu une
tentative de d'agression en sortie de
boîte ù deux personnes ont failli se
faire tuer heureusement des des
courageux videur ont pu intervenir mais
ces drames là quotidiens si on arrive
pas en parler sérieusement si on arrive
pas essayer de trouver des solutions
ensemble ça va finir par par exploser ça
va finir par mettre le pays à feu à 100
et je crois que justement si on veut
résoudre ces problèmes il faut mettre
les bombes au dessus et moi j'ai une
vraie pensée pour la famille de Thomas
son âme village tout le village qui est
traumatisé oui 89 % voilà g vous étiez
dans le vrai pour une fois euh merci
Stanislas rig je crois que vous allez
revenir nous voir vendredi on va passer
à l'invité du soir je vous dirai
pourquoit vendredi je suis en direct
très bien merci voilà ça me fait plaisir
vous êtes gratuit euh on va passer à
l'invité du
soir